the supreme court decision could have an
effect on mental health jeremy j ford
visited with a specialist at the
foundation recovery center today to
discuss the impact of the supreme court
decision he joins us now in the newsroom
with more jeremy
well thanks sasha carrying out a
pregnancy can already cause changes in
the body physically and mentally i spoke
with andrea hitchcock a specialist here
in the valley who helps give women the
recovery and support they need during
their pregnancy i think women should
have a right to make decisions on their
own body mental health specialist drea
hitchcock tells me the decision to
overturn roe versus wade could have dire
consequences for women especially for
those who have been assaulted in states
where abortions have been banned mental
health is going to come into effect
where
i think that they should have resources
out there if they're feeling they have
no outlet here in the valley the
foundation for recovery offers help
resources and a place for people to get
the information they need if they're
experiencing a mental health crisis we
have the center which is located off the
maryland parkway they teach us about
safe sex all the time they pass out
condoms the foundation of recovery they
also pass out condoms they have great
resources that tell us where to go if
you need some help
here you go
[Music]
well the foundation for recovery is open
monday through friday from 9 a.m to 5
p.m from the newsroom jeremy j ford is
live local now